good morning good afternoon
and welcome everyone welcome to today's
live broadcast
latest thinking and scar prevention and
treatment a guide to managing
and treating scars i'm alexis krause of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths and
sponsored by
alliance pharmaceuticals for more
information about our sponsor
please visit their website at
alliancepharmaceuticals.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click on the send button if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr luke thiel
former head plastic and reconstructive
department at the university hospital
montpellier president and founding
member of g
scarf's global scar society for a
complete biography on our presenter
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr teo you may now begin your
presentation
welcome sir
good morning my name is luke theo i am
assistant professor
of plastic reconstructive surgery in
montpelier university
hospital and i will speak
today about a guide to managing and
treating
scars using a silicone
and mainly kelo coat
we will speak about the disc cars which
is a
a group of experts uh along the
world we'll speak about fundamentals
about the
guidelines consensus about the
some agentive treatment approaches a
kind of
patient journey clinical cases
and the possibilities and role of
helicopters car management
and prevention
the global scar society was built from a
previous international group
which was a club the scar club which was
funded
in 2006 in in montpellier the discusses
focus on
research and therapy to promote car
management
and prevention help develop research
around scaring create educational and
informational sports
and recommend an international
assistance service for specific problems
a petrofix cars caloids car atrophy and
other type of pathological scaling
lead to a poor cosmetic
and functional outcomes but the discard
aims to bring together
all disciplines and stakeholders in the
field
promoting either mechanical or and
chemical approaches aiming to normalize
the lives of patients with pathological
scars
fundamentals normal wounded
in fact is a cascade of events from
inflammation to maturation
four four key wound leading phases
which overlap hemostasis inflammation
blood proliferation remodeling and scar
maturation
in fact in terms of timing hemostasis
lasts some seconds sometimes a little
bit longer
but usually very short inflammatory
phase
from hours to some days depending on
the level on different factors we'll
come back on that
the proliferative phase the days two
weeks the remodeling phase
is much longer weeks to months and
if we have the the sequence of
of of events from injury we have a
the first uh phase of vasoconstriction
platelet aggregation and locussive
migration
uh then on the inflammatory phase the
early neutrophil chemoattractant
relief late macrophages phagocytosis and
removal
of brain bodies and bacteria the
during the proliferation phase
fiberglass proliferation
collagen synthesis extracellular matrix
reorganization
angiogenesis granulation disinformation
and
finally epithelialization but it's not
finished
epithelialization doesn't guarantee that
there will not
be any pathological events it's
done during remodeling remodeling is
after coverage by epithelium
there is an extracellular matrix
remodeling
an increase in tensile strength of
the wound and the edges and the futures
or
whatever and then we come to yield
tissue healing ill tissue is very
long time after the injury may last many
years
in some training for example
the classification of pathologic scars
can be reduced to
two scenarios one hypertrophy scars
there is an excessive scar proliferation
that does not extend
beyond the edges of the initial wound
very important
the growth starts some months after
wound closure
three to three months after which the
progression usually stops and the scar
gradually becomes questioned and
stabilized
the full maturation process may take up
to two years but it may also regress
within one year depending on
manufacturers attention particle
calories is different because it's a
benign proliferation
extending over the edges of the initial
wound
can grow with time without signs of
stabilization
can start directly after completed one
closure
or later than a year may appear
spontaneously but
do not regress continuously and the high
recurrence rate after
adjust surgical exe
the risk factors of pathological scaring
are
multiple the great number of surgical
interventions
area of high tension after surgery and
one closure
on the back of the shoulder on the
sternum
lower abdomen we have high tension
we have our attention on scars that
cross joints
or skin creases at right angle
injuries affecting deeper layers of the
skin longer time to wound healing
very important very important because in
burns
specifically darker skin types
for calories mainly young adults
adolescents
much more frequent than in older
people elderly or adults
and persistence of local information
whatever be the cause
can be infection it can be tension
can be a specific area or a specific
type of skin
in term of consensus we started in 2002
and established a sequence of strategies
starting at the end of the first month
and during all along
the evolution of the scar so first of
all we have a medical strategy
so we define at risk patients and we try
to prevent
the occurrence of pathological scars and
we have different strategies
sequential for one three and six months
on the other side we have the surgical
strategy which starts very early
prevention the prevention means best
practice in surgery it's always
very important to remember
and post surgery we can either
replace with flaps thermal substitutes
or tissue expansion we can also try to
improve a base card using laser
using radiotherapy micro needling
cryotherapy
mechanical peeling drafting sculpturing
you see
the number of possible surgical
strategies and we're still balancing
between because in scars we have a very
few
high-level evidence based
medicine so most of the time we work on
consensus
there are consensus on lasers there are
consensus on
different types of treatments local or
invasive or less invasive so we try at
these cars
to compensate all these
possible actions and try to propose
consensus and guidelines as we did
last year and we do it this year with a
book which is
appearing at springer
if we look at patients at risk of
scalable
following surgery which means we know
that the type of surgery may uh
be a source of other physical so we are
working we are speaking about
prevention so we have a surgery or
trauma
and we know perfectly how to practice
good technique
wound management to reduce the risk of
scarring
but we have the risk of scarring so the
risk of carrying
maybe a high risk left and usually
systematically we will use silicon gel
or
heating with or without intransitional
corticosteroid injection
on the right we have low risk but is the
patient
concerned by his scar and yes we will
also use silicone gel or silicone
sheeting
he's not concerned we have a standard
country being of
prevention to exposure to to sun
and if the risk of scaring is increasing
in the central part then we we will
protect using silicone gel or
sheathing or hypoallergenic paper tape
or
onion extract cream and others
are typical i would say uh prop results
post surgery perfectly we have a a
a booming
solution which are coming since
the last two or three years
one of them is very simple is the ogawa
tape which is a scary strip called
adasive sutures which is a specialized
quintet to reduce wind tension
mildly i would say and support scar
tissue
we begin this type of
mechanical uh limited
system to uh uh just after suture
removal
and then for at least three months so
it's a little bit controlling
for the contraining for the for the
patient
ogawa tips contains steroids and is used
for
uh one month onwards
on the on the right you see something
which is
proposed and the very smart
system uh composed of instead of uh
sutures glue stakes and trips it's it's
a system which
will finish the future
and as far as you have a dermal perfect
future you can prevent to have an
epithelial
future ring by using this system
which is just a mechanical uh
strips which are uh capable to uh
to progress uh uh to make the the two
edges of the scar
progressing to each other no pain
no scar pigmentation
vascularization can be seen at different
times points in the post-operative
period compared with with staples
there is an improved car vascularity
pigmentation
pliability and hate uh their
futures and uh some randomized control
trials
were recently
realized with a zip massage therapy is
is very good
it's often recommended we are speaking
here about scars after burn injury
it may prevent really improve
hypertrophic scarring
reduces uh scar pain itching
thickness discoloring and redness
it may decrease the transmitted
epidermal
water loss as you see here
different uh variations on massage
using the hands or using machines some
machines can
uh can be used also with some aspiration
system inside
which may uh help into
reducing the abnormal collagen
proliferation
negative pressure wound therapy made a
lot of evidence
during the last three four years
with good randomized control trials
proposing
to stabilize during the post-operative
period
using negative pressure when therapy the
edges of
the sutures and to create some
aspiration of the fluid which could come
from this future
so double action one prevention
of post-operative infection and
prevention of
one day sense
it's sealed to make a tight the the
ceiling may uh
come to uh small
come to to the to the dressing most of
the time
uh this uh it helps to to reduce post
post health recall infection by uh
making the
small amount of liquid uh issuing from
the future
uh collected in the dressing you see
here
with the two examples of uh
medical devices proposed in in in
negative pressure wound therapy
after surgery which is called incisional
negative pressure with turkey
the medical strategy after one month can
use also
different
options laser therapy is one option
which is
frequently used especially in adia
in korea very frequently because
even the the transient inflammation the
redness
which occur after burn or after trauma
or even after surgery
may lead to some cosmetic
problems or difficulties for the patient
so laser therapy became very popular
in this period in this post-operative
figure or post-trauma
a pdl or yag one month for two three
months
must affect me for hypertrophic scar
or for flat calories limited efficacy
for
sicker scars and
large calories fractional laser therapy
if kdl is ineffective
which induces a wounded response a
second wounded response
resulting in increased type 3 collagen
production and promotion of scar
remodeling so it's
different possibilities to use some
ablative lasers will uh may also be
used but we will come back microneedling
is
uh well something which
became popular during the last two years
uh it's a repetitive application
on stretched car horizontally vertically
and
lightly to achieve a uniform
pinpoint bleeding to induce
a new wound in cascade
so uh this is uh aggressive
but uh may uh induce a little bit like
peeling induce something which is uh
re-restarting of the wounded link
especially the growth factors and a kind
of
reactivation of
epithelialization and reorientation of
the collagen fibers
cars treated with vitamin a and vitamin
c
cream for at least one month before and
after mixed microneedling
to maximize the dermal collagen
synthesis
may be added
after three months most of the time
especially in burns
pressure garments compressive garbage
are proposed
they were promoted by french specialists
and
reimbursed in france there is no strong
evidence-based
data but it's used widely and accepted
everywhere
even in u.s or in
east countries it may be difficult to
find a garment that
fits the wounded area properly that most
of
of of them are realized
just adapted to this shape and and the
size
and the the patients often find wearing
the dressing or garments
uncomfortable and they do not always
adhere to the to the guidance especially
young people uh girls uh
they don't want to show up uh with these
garments and
this is why in some um well in some
occasions uh
uh other other
options are are proposed uh
like making up uh in for a very
transient
period of time
in transitional therapies maybe uh where
were developed
with different uh
drugs one of them is five few
five few is an intimidating drug
very well known in digestive cancer
especially and uh it has been demons
starting in the in in us
with the long gecko team in san
francisco
and progressively adopted by the chinese
colleagues
then german colleagues with a different
type of proposals
starting with very low doses but
now high doses
means 50 meals
by 50 microgram per meal
are sometimes proposed essentially in
germany
and also in in france it enhances
calorie regression
in most of 45 percent of the patient
and the recurrence
of treated in calories in
less than 50 percent of patients
localized effects include include pain
it's painful
at the injection shine hyperpigmentation
uh skin irritation and ulceration when
the doses are very high
but usually it's uh well-tolerated
periods trying synonyms
thought to inhibit fibroblast growth and
tgf-beta and use collagen type 1
expression
the response rate of 50 to 100 percent
but the recurrence rate
were estimated in different trials
to nine between nine and fifty percent
we have complications if if the
injection is not
strictly inside the scar if the
subcutaneous tissue around
are injected and especially the the fat
and you have fat atrophy which
renders the cosmetic aspect worse
than so needs to be done by people who
know
but um toxin a
well the mechanism of action is still
unclear
and the data are inadequate for the
movement
it's more effective than traditional
steroids
well supposedly but
well discussion still was the bottling
on
toxin because well the minimal side
effects but the
the the effect is this is not
very very important
uh after six months we can also use the
autologous fat grafting with adipose
stem cells it's a
recent strategy which can
very simple to realize in the or can
improve the scalp pliability the colon
the thickness
and reduce pain in hypertrophic and
mature scars
known to tolerate harvest
and grass injection better than mature
adipocytes
produce gross factors that promote
angiogenesis
and stimulate endothelial cells
fibroblasts and tissue progenitor cells
to remodel the scar tissue and well
some evidence appear and uh many
surgeons would adopt that because it's
they
they find it quite effective uh the
there's an analgesic effect of uh
this adipose themselves which are
mediated
via nerve reaper and release of
contractions because you can inject
that after release the mechanical
release surgical release of contracture
as a prevention of a recontractor and
you interpose
some adipose stem cells uh between the
the two layers uh you see uh uh
post-injection cost excision
radiotherapy in calories is also
uh was a source of debates
10 years ago but solved more or less by
an extensive review of literature
which makes that radiotherapy by itself
is not causing any cancer degenerations
or
big problems i would say it's used to
prevent recurrence by inhibiting new
calorie dosgenic inflammation via immune
cell inhibition and neurovascularization
initially a conventional photon being
radiotherapy was used but more recently
electron beam radiotherapy and backing
therapy are used
with small doses and uh
the different radiation doses are
depending on the location
of the keloid with a max of 30 degrees
one week after excision and it reduces
recurrence rates to 10 percent or less
we have good
evidence that this injection realized
quite quite early after surgery has an
important
effect on preventing the recruits
in terms of surgical strategy uh
remember we spoke about we evoked the
the good surgical principles
good surgical principles means tissue
trauma
during these dissections good hygiene
tension-free wind closure respect of
language line
all residents in surgery in plastic
surgery
should know where the longest line are
and don't make an incision crossing
this line and just do the incision
parallel or inside
the lines in order to have the minimal
cosmetic
complication in term of post-surgery
after surgery
uh the the proposals consensual proposal
of the scars are
an intelligent silicon reapproximating
scar edges
scatter replicating device including
silicone
or device regulating skin tension over
the edges like the zip
or negative pressure post surgical
assistance
we have hoped that pico prevana or aval
and then fat basking if needed
some months after
so surgical if we if we evoke the scar
replacement
it's impossible we have tried to remodel
to change a little bit the orientation
of the collagen
but it doesn't work then we have to
think about removing the scar
and changing the aspect of the scar
using
different solutions in terms of
surgery we have a disposal
flaps either free flaps or pedicle flaps
or local flaps we have thermal
substitutes
plus skin grafting and we have
also overgrafting replacing
an hypertrophy scar a kilowatt by a skin
graft
harvested on the same patient another
another
scar is created or tissue expansion
and we have some examples of
combining microsurgery by a tissue
carrier for example
and tissue extension which bring a flap
large enough to cover
the face or to cover a very large area
example a local flap
that you see here to cover the
the heel which is transferring
the skin which is in the middle part of
the foot to the back
part of the foot and creating a a
lot of tissue on the on the
middle part of the foot and this loss of
tissue will be
covered using skin grafting
this is the rotation flap
which is classical in plastic surgery
you can use regional flap you can use
perforate or flap which are
just uh possibility of
dissecting the flap but also one vessel
one artery one vein which makes this
vertical an axis of rotation of
trans trans transplantation
of of this flap to another area
distant flap makes a micro surgical
revascularization
or combined free flap like the one you
see on the right
which is coming from the shoulder and
which was created
with the model of uh of technique which
is called prefabrication
and we published like we published this
technique a long time ago and uh
landsat uh and you see uh
how it was uh during a surgery before
the coverage of this scarred area on on
on the neck so it's an uh this expansion
will bring the next
key uh same area more or less or the
proximal area because the the the color
uh
matches uh with uh with the area which
will be which will receive this flap the
texture and the thickness
of the surrounding skin are of the same
aspect and and the same sensation
very low risk of complication and the
remaining skin
uh will cover the donor skin region
means we don't harvest all the flap we
just harvest
what what is needed and the rest of
expanded tissue will be
able to reapproximate and cover
the donor site area well also some
agentive treatment approaches
and we evoked letters in
pathology called scar prevention
there is an uh a recent paper
uh published by a french colleague
with make a
randomized control trial with a single
pass
during the post-operative period with a
12-10 nanometers laser treatment
performed immediately after surgery it
was on
breast surgery it was a prospective
randomized double blind control trial
40 women underlying bilateral breast
reduction
with inverted t scars laser
versus no laser per breath
six months after surgery the scar volume
was measured
and we had 36 they had 36
percent lower when they applied the last
treatment
versus no treatment at one year the
volume
of the scar was 29 lower roughness was
17 surface was 10 11
lower and from week six to one years
uh the patient expressed a preference
for the breast treated village
another adjective treatment is
photobiomodulation
which require an application of a
chromophore containing
gel which is activated by lead
so a lead lamp will activate the gel you
see on the on the
on on the knee of this patient that
there is a
kind of pouch including the chromophores
and the the lead will activate the
chromophore making the chromophore
uh uh giving a a a range of different
length wave uh of uh different so it's
it's not strictly a laser it's in
between it's a
capacity to expose a scar
two different length wave coming from
the same machine the same combination
between the the chromophores and the lab
the investigator
published many studies one of them
allowed them to conclude that the first
treatment is
uh during the week after surgery
and the sixth treatment of five minutes
each and
a six months follow-up
if we come to epidemiology we have to
say that
for the moment there are not
very conclusive trials
we have several attempts to demonstrate
that
this cell culture epidermal
cell culture where efficient
uh episel which is cultured epidermal
autographed composed
of the patient's own predation of
science grown ex-vivo
in the presence of proliferation
arrested luline
fibroblasts or ap6 which is a dihydrated
amniotic
chorionic membrane allograft or epi skin
which is a reconstructed juvenile
epidermis from normal
human keratinocyte culture on the
collagen matrix so allergenic
schematic lhe which is a reconstruction
humanities from normal human to its
massage cultures on an
inert polycarbonate feature you see that
different attempts others
which are well the essential of
bioengineered skin substitutes which
isn't
hopefully becoming better and better
each year
but you see that depending on where you
live
depending on the regulations you have in
the u.s
you can use everything in europe
you cannot use cellularized using
allergenic cells
[Music]
so there is a differences
in different continents i would say
coming to non cell right
you have nylon match or collagen dermis
and silicone covered by a silicone film
a cellular matrices from bovine or
porcine collagen
integra very well known much
or another one a new one which is
develia
a cellular matrices from yellow urolic
acid like
yellow matrix or allogenic substitutes
from coming from cadaver skins
essentially in us allow them
if you go to cellularize using
allergenic cells
you may have just fibrobus or
keratinocytes
and or fibroblasts typically neonatal
foreskin
a fibroblast with a mesh of matrix
or allogenic matrices from neonate
human fibroblasts like cell adam or
dermograph
or allogenic composite matrices from
human keratinocytes
fibroblasts with bovine or porcelain
collagen like apple graph
or cell or transceive and
if we go to cellularize using otolubu
cell
there is one which is coming french
bordeaux
which is called genus skin very
ambitious
but some evidence that
on an acellular matrix matrix
they were able to make a epidermal
tissue epidermal cells
cultivated in a period of time which is
short
between two weeks and three weeks
and different from what we got until now
so promises
history engineering is
well a topic of high interest a lot of
research
everywhere in the world because the new
skin would certainly be
a very important step forward
in term of reconstruction so dermal
or epidermal dermal epidermal or
composite
skin substitutes and to mimic the
ontological structure of normal skin
where both epidermal and dermal layers
are
present this allows some functional
resemblance to the normal skin and
although
seen as a sophisticated and advanced
choice there have been reports of
immune rejections uh concerning
essentially epidemic because
a dermal component in human
has no capacity of immunologically
uh reject in order to prevent rejection
new approaches of keratinocyte cell
culture
uh multiplying the past edges
uh and other thermal 52 have been
recently developed this is again the
genius
scheme we have emerging technologies
and like extracorporeal shockwave
therapy
thought to improve scalar appearance
reducing fibroblast density and collagen
fiber thickness
which gave a benefit on many types of
wounds and scars with little discomfort
it hurts a little bit but a few
complications and
very easy in terms of application in
patients presenting hypertrophic scar
the the technique improves car aids
pliability pigmentation
and vascularity and platelet which
would rich plasma prp which by itself
is another world many solutions
many techniques many combinations
the basic principle is an autologous
blood derived product
with platelets with a local application
which causes a suprasy geological
release of gross factor
that modulates pathway involving tissue
inflammation and repair
results is an increase in collagen and
elastic fibers
and can be injected or just topically
applied
during and after micro needling and we
evoke that
rehabilitation by itself
it's also a world and it's uh different
if you live in u.s or if you live in
europe
if you live in in asia because
you have uh millions of options
from ambulatory to specialized centers
depending on
if you have just a cosmetic problem or
if you have just a transitory
inflammation
or if you have a serious uh impairment
of your function uh function in the
um in a joint function in uh
in in in the neck in uh in the
different uh anatomical locations so
in these rehabilitation centers or in
these rehabilitation techniques
you may have some differences we spoke
about compression garment
some of them are coated with silicone
plinths
please
hard to to wear but efficient in terms
of
hand rehabilitation massage
and we spoke about that physiotherapy
different types of massage
hydrotherapy and psychological support
in some
countries you have hydrotherapy in
specialized centers
for the end of maturation process with
the
softness of the skin being improved by
this hydrotropic
solution
in terms of clinical cases we have
selected two cases
one is kilometer
an asean origin patient
19 years old and we
we opted for five few
long term treatments repetitive
treatment more than
six months using five fu to decrease
fibroblast proliferation and after six
months or five
fu injected locally at the
well every month
at the beginning and then every week at
the end
we ended with a surgery and we
look at on the right the
aspect one year after surgery so the
recurrence
seems really decreased
by preparing before surgery
the local risk of re-proliferation
of the fibroblasts
if we use co2 lasers especially in burns
to treat hypertrophic scars which are
scarcely extended
over the uh of the area this card area
uh then you you will uh uh with co2
laser you will remove
uh it's an ablative laser so we will
improve the height
of the scar we still have uncertain
results on
pigmentation because melanocytes
are different from keratin of science
and there are a few techniques
which are really efficient on
re-segmentation
so you see the results after the
procedure six months after
speaking about calor code in scar
management and prevention
we have some guidelines
on abnormal carrying for
hypertrophic and kilns so in 2002
when we started with tom musto to uh
well to propose the first international
consensual guidelines it highlighted the
primary role for silicone gel cheating
in the management
of a wide variety of variety variability
of abnormal scars in 2014
some other guidelines and our guidelines
were proposed and
concluded that silicon-based products
are efficacious in carrying prophylaxis
and management of hybrid office cars
newer gel preparations overcome
limitations
inherent in gel sheeting gel sitting is
difficult to wear
a gel is more easy to handle
and silicone sheeting or gel is
universally considered as the first line
prophylactic and treatment option
for hypertrophic and minor kilohertz
scopes
and in 2020 you have the question mark
on should we change should we come
from a gel to another option
what are the respective advantage of
silicon versus
silicon sheets on the left you have the
silicon gel sheets
and some skin issues
may occur like pruritus skin rash or
skin maceration we don't observe that
that with silicone gel of course
the other emanating for the gel sheet is
not
observed using a silicon gel
silicon gel sheets is very limited in
terms of indications for scars located
adjacent to joint
because of the restricted movement and
adherence
which is not the case for for silicon
gel
which can be used for skin falls and
hairy areas
the appearance in visible areas for the
gel sheets
because it it can stay it cannot stay by
itself
you need to have a fixation system with
this sheet
uh silicone gel is discreet transparent
you can
you can apply that on the nose on on the
front
on a visible area the the compliance of
the patient is poor
using sheets because it's something
which is boring to wear
for silicon gel it's the acceptability
testing is much better
gel sheet may require taping to hold in
place
and the gel advanced by itself
gel sheets can be reusable washing
between used but shown to have a poor
durability
and the silicone gel has a two-time
daily application for 20 hours of
treatment sheet is not
suitable for large area and the gel can
be applied easily to larger vr
particularly with the spray the version
of the
of the gel which is on spray and may
cause excessive sweating
in hot humid climates when using sheets
and it's preferred for hot humid
climates
the mod of action is the same it was
developed by tom musto some years ago
they may help silicon products may help
to prevent excessive scar formation
by restoring the water barrier through
occlusion
and hydration of the stratum corneum and
need
to be used as soon as the wound suture
is healed so very quickly
very early
masto and his team or soft nation
use the rabbit model which is excessive
thermal scarring very difficult in
in in animals to find the model of
excessive dermal scarring
helicopter was compared with tissue
adhesive
in their meal and barrier filled cavilon
with
treatment starting at day 14. the
control was
no treatment and the negative control of
tape stripping
each rabbit was their own control one
ear
with either occlusion or ts and the
other ear
no treatment the scar elevation index
was
significantly reduced with scalar codes
and other treatments when compared with
no occlusion with a p lower than
0.05 the ewl
trans trans-epidermal water loss was
reduced
with all treatments so occluded wounds
may be in advanced state of
repair this is a conclusion and you see
the
difference in term of current epidermal
water loss
on below
so randomized controlled trial in 30
patients
another study with bilateral immature
scars hyperfix scars vocabulary scars
and for each patient one scar was
treated and the other left
untreated each patient was assigned to
one of the three groups
keloco applied morning and evening
silicone gel sitting applied every day
and left in place
during the morning and night yellow
coats applied in the morning at silicon
valley shooting at
night elevations included
evaluations included redness height and
softening of the scars
this was uh the conclusion calcutta
reduced sky height
by a greater amount than silicon gel
sheeting or no treatment
so here we have an important
step forward because there is a
more efficacy with the silicon gel
due to all the different aspects we
already
presented
halo code reduced also starring with
emma with a greater amount
than silicone gel shooting or no
treatment and we have an erythema score
comparing the treated scar and treated
the scar
for each group telecoil on the left
silicone gel sheet
on the right another
uh item was
called reducing symptom of itching
irradiation in maceration after
90 days of treatment and again you see
the differences
on uh with a p lower than
0.001
patients stated that skelecote was far
easier to use than silicone gel sheeting
because of the spray telecot made a
during
the treatment regimen easier than
silicone gel sheeting
again you have this p-value which is
very
uh important in term of significance
silicon gel in hypertrophic and kerose
car prevention
uh prospective randomized parallel group
comparison study with two arms
80 patients with scalar codes among them
72 completed study and 80 patients had
no treatment unless they showed signs of
hypertrophy
and 76 completed the study the main
cause of
surgery was benign or malignant skin
lesions
needing needing excision and also
included scar revision
and cosmetic surgery like breast
augmentation
and reconstruction twice daily local
treatment
compared with no treatments from ten
days to three weeks after surgery
for four months patients were evaluated
using a four grade scale
over six months of treatment and this is
uh
two thirds of patients who use scalar
code did not develop at
abnormal scarring after four months of
treatment
a further 26 percent develop only mildly
hypertrophic scars
only one patient who receives kerocot
developed a kilowatt
and you see the different patients in a
study
published in 2007 with
different grades and comparing kelocot
in blue
and no treatment in green
so what is the significance of
kilocot uv kilocot uv
uh well it's a combination
guidelines recommend avoiding exposure
of wounds to the sun
all of them it's a need it's a need
because
it reduces inflammation kilocot uv
contains spf 30 which can absorb
up to 97 of the
radiation coming from uv
b so adding that
will certainly help in
preventing exposure to the sun uh
because sometimes you you cannot uh
prevent exposure to the sun because of
different uh
uh uh different uh mods of life
or uh of way to do it uh
the uv radiation i
said that already is associated with the
scar hyper implementation
so some results
yellow coat uv before kellogg uv
on the left and you see different types
of
scars one on the abdomen the other
just below the
the eye and after three months of
kilocal's uv
treatment you see the aspect and uh
this is uh something which is quite
spectacular i would say
in summary the
treatments next to silicone gels
increasing focus on
five few fractional lasers
prevention of unpleasant scarring is
more effective and treatment affects
existing scars so please
try to think about the scar when you
operate
focus on good surgical practice and
and and a post-operative mechanical
control
many surgeons don't see anymore their
patients
after surgery and you should think about
that
and have a look one month after your
surgery patients are at risk
systematically silicon during
after immediately after healing many
products on the market
so you have to advise patients you have
to
show them what is the gradation between
these
different options sun protection for all
of them
and silicon sheets if there is a
competence
and a stronger focus on single gels
which are easy to handle you can have in
your pocket
you don't need to hide yourself if
worsening of the scar occurs
patients should return to the treating
doctor as
soon as possible and
in terms of calculate the magnitude of
occlusion provided by silicon therapy
appears to be critical the unique
patented formulation of color codes
leads to a thin robust breathable
effective layer that remains on the skin
for a launch period
and providing occlusion comparable with
silicone sheets
but it's better in terms of
compliance a clinical beneficial effect
of
calories scaling is comparable to
kilocut gel sheets
and that has been demonstrated in
various studies in more than
more than close to 2000 patients for the
treatment and
prophylaxis of pathophysiological
scarring you will find here some
references which are very useful when
you
speak or talk about scars because even
if
the evidence base is not very high you
have a lot of
references concerning scars which is a
universal problem uh everywhere in the
world
and you see what the the most
striking important references
which are summarized here
63 important references i would say
and i thank you for your attention
thank you dr teo for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first
questions our first question is
so dr teo as more as more advanced
treatments come to the fore
will there still be a place for older
therapies in the prevention
and treatment of scarring
yes um i think uh siliconism
is is quite old it started
in 1983 in australia so
it's an old story the the the the
old silicon is difficult to apply
difficult to maintain on site and uh
well yes all therapies uh like
lasers also but we
it happens now that laser people
dermatologists or surgeons uh practicing
lasers are using silicon
in combination so yes there are a few
places for older therapies
but it's such a booming in terms of
medical devices uh
solutions techniques that
the older therapies are a little bit
disappeared i would say
wonderful thank you so much so dr teo
our next question
are sap cut sutures still required with
the zip system
uh good question uh
i think that the using the deep you will
close the epidermis uh the
the the deep part of the of the future
should be secured
and uh i think as far as you can
mechanically improve the resistance of
enlarging
by having a deep suturing
uh using resolvable material and limit
the effect of the zip to just
the epithelium i think it's it will be
better
but another point concerning the zip is
uh the company is
proposing two two weeks of of treatment
in some occasions like you have to
reject
some benign to tuber over the the nose
or in in tension areas you you may
prolong
the the use of the of the zip even if
it's not very cosmetically
accepted but the final result is is
quite good uh
and in some some skin rejections
after burns for as carbons you may
prolonged the zip for for for one month
and a half
thank you dr tia so we do have time for
one more question but i do want to
remind our audience that
any questions that we are unable that we
were unable to answer today and those
that
do come in during the on-demand period
they will be addressed uh
by our speaker via the email address
that you provided at the time of
registration
okay so dr t our final question for you
today
is there do you have any advice on
treating skin type
5 or 6 with very dark stretch marks
thighs
buttocks for example you know laser
therapy or
retinoids yeah
laser uh laser is by itself is
the world so uh depending on the on the
it's just a dark
uh you have some uh uh ablative laser
which can uh lighten a little bit this
uh dark marks
dye laser also may improve the color
as far as you get some fibrous tissue
you have to combine and to to start with
some
some ablative laser taking uh care and
and be very cautious about the the the
the
the the the wavelengths
uh because depending on on on
well not not to be too too deep in term
of uh
ablation but uh this is a real uh big
issue
and uh uh i would go for for laser
uh uh first uh
another at the contrary another uh
big big issue is uh acromic scar
where for the moment i just uh
we had this discussion at the g scars
and the only
uh solution is the solution coming from
australia
from fiona wood whose name is resale
which can bring some melanocyte over
these
discolored areas in in
in dark skins
perfect thank you so much dr teo before
we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and again those that are submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
so we would like to once again thank you
dr teo for your time today and your
important
research we would also like to thank
labbert and our sponsor
alliance pharmaceuticals for
underwriting today's educational webcast
you are able to view the webinar on
demand labert's will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
that's all for now thank you for joining
us
and until next time bye bye everyone
bye thank you